ladies and gentlemen welcome to the Tim
Dillon show thank you to everybody who
came out to the
Barry Weiss event that I uh did comedy
in front of the very important
uh
Barry Weiss
event
it was a debate sponsored by the Mossad
in which we discussed the proposition
should woman should woman
should women start getting hit again in
the movies should they start getting
punched in the face you know but in kind
of a romantic way like to calm her down
and the answer was no but it was close
uh 51-49 and the great Anna
hashian kashian from Red Scare was there
and she was the funniest one
uh but Louise Perry was there as well
who's very smart and then Sarah Hader
who's really smarter than Grimes who's
very entertaining and uh you know Smart
in her own way and uh it was a good uh
it was a good day I stayed about 40
minutes and I did and that was fine that
was more than enough
I mean Jesus Christ I heard about that
after party it's on a rooftop and you
know
it's just you know you do it it's fun
you move on
it doesn't need you know it doesn't have
to be a convention so
thank you Barry for including me I
appreciate it and um
you know everybody uh more and more
people are on those epic that's all I
can tell you everybody I bump into in
Hollywood and Los Angeles is Ono's epic
and uh
it's a miracle drug apparently but in
rare cases you can get uh something
called gastro
poriasis or paresis where your stomach
refuses to empty it will not empty out
so you're nauseous kind of for the rest
of your life when eating food but that
is very rare
cases but everyone you meet
in this town is on ozempic I'm not gonna
say who's on it but I'm saying people
you bump into and they go are you wanna
know that big I'm honest and I'm happy
for everybody that's on it and uh who
knows I might do it I'm a [__]
I'm a [__]
and doctors they're telling me they
don't know if I should do it and I mean
doctors these people are the scum of the
earth they'll tell you to do anything
really
so if doctors are saying just we don't
know yet doctors
their jobs just to sell your [__] if
they are telling you to wait doctor the
lowest of the low
doctors
people they have to literally make them
do the Hippocratic Oath first Do no harm
they have to make them say that because
they know how sick they are in the head
doctors if they're even saying wait
maybe or
let's see what happens and some of them
aren't some of them are going go for it
we don't know but a lot of them are
afraid now because of that thing on
Netflix called painkiller where
everybody is mad at the sacklers
and I'll tell you this I found it my
mother's I found out at my mother's wake
she was a pharmaceutical rep she was one
of those hot chicks she used to be hot
and she was like selling speed and stuff
and I was so proud of her what did by
the way
let me Mount
a much needed defense of the Sackler
family right now let me because I
haven't heard any there's none
there's not one person defending the
sacklers I thought about it the other
day I said everybody you know has
betrayed these people they've deserted
them in their hour of need
there's not one person willing to say
maybe this is a two-sided issue maybe
there's more to this maybe somebody had
a bad back
here's the deal does it or not does it
work or not that's number one does it
work or not are you still in pain or not
from the boating accident do you feel
better after the boating accident or not
or do you want Aleve
they created a product that works and
the problem is it worked too well
and they knew it worked really really
really really well that's the whole
point of that show they knew how well it
worked and they kind of were like hey
we're just gonna let you know it's good
but we don't want to tell you it's that
good we don't want to tell you it's
great
and I'm aware
that hindsight is 20 20. the Monday
morning quarterbacking is Big everybody
likes to beat up on the family that got
us all addicted to opioids okay I
understand that
instinctually maybe I might even agree
with it if I were of a lesser mind as
many of you are I wish I was that in
that condition in that state
because it must be easier to kind of go
through life questioning nothing
and always walking around by the way
they have a grape
Wing at the Museum of Natural History
that's beautiful
that's got CR get up to Sackler Wing at
the Museum of Natural History
because that's good
it's it's not only if you've made money
it's what have you done with your money
and now all these boards are going let's
let's give back their money what about
all the money that they they took from
like these [__] military industrial
complex groups that have literally
killed people all over the world but
that money is good but the money from
the Sackler family is not good
don't you think it's odd by the way that
we only have a problem with one family
in the pharmaceutical World Isn't that
strange that it's one evil family and no
one else nobody else has done anything
wrong there's no other drug that we
should look at it's just just Oxycontin
there's no other meds out there that we
may not need with the most medicated
country in the world but there's nothing
else that's a problem the only thing
that's a problem is literally the most
obvious thing the most obvious thing
that turns people into zombies running
around will criticize that but isn't it
interesting that we've directed all does
anyone find that interesting that we've
directed all of our attention to one
family and the ruling class has decided
to evict them from the boards of museums
and Charities and they've decided to
give back their donations and say your
money's no good hair take your money
away we only take money from the
military and people that do only God
we only take money from people that do
only good things like Boeing don't you
think it's odd that there's this one
family that everybody's focused on this
one evil family of evil people that were
born evil
they're born evil
it's odd to me it seems like we've
scapegoated them
I'm not telling people to do Oxycontin I
liked Percocet stick with Percocet
that's the message of the show the
message of the show Vicodin might not be
enough for you I understand that
vicodin's light it's a mom thing I used
to do open houses with a fat realtor
named nula and she used to give me
Vicodin and we used to walk ourselves
because no one would come to the open
houses we used to do them on this small
island Harbor aisle where I grew up it
doesn't matter you can Google it and we
used to walk around the island you know
and all viked up and it feels nice
because your joints kind of Glide but
the point is if you want to get you know
I get that doesn't seem fun maybe to
people listening but then you do
Percocet because perkas that's nice
but that's habit forming as well but
Oxycontin I remember I took it a few
times I ended up on a couch me and my
buddy just kind of going uh staring at
each other we got like dope sick it's
not fun
it's not fun but pretending that it is
the only drug that is a problem in this
country it is the only thing that we
should monitor it all it is the only the
only pharmaceutical problem we have is
the evil Sackler family with uh
Oxycontin that's it that's the only
issue there's not nobody else is pushing
anything on you you shouldn't take
nobody you know because all those 18
year old kids
collapsing on Soccer Fields having heart
attacks because of Oxycontin right
it's all bad
I love when by the way
it's gonna sound crazy but go with me
here
when all of the rich people decide to
evict one rich family
take the side of the family they've
evicted
listened to me not emotionally take your
emotions out for a minute
what I'm saying is when all of these
people
decide that one group of people that
they all knew what they were doing there
was nobody that didn't know how the
sacklers made their money there was no
one that didn't know
so what are you guys in machine parts
what do you guys do are you in Port
export what do you do do you run art
galleries what do you do they knew it
everyone knew how they made their money
there's not one group of they're all at
the dinner party
ending to sacklers are there and
everybody's going like how they
how are they everyone knew everyone knew
some of the people took the drug some of
the people drum roll please
we're in on it they were they were
invested they thought it was great
they just didn't come up with the thing
so this one family
who created this drug
that has become a nightmare for people
I don't Advocate drug use I'm sober for
12 years
the only reason I'm able to do anything
as a human being on this planet is
because I am sober
if you even think you have a drug or
alcohol problem you do and you should
get help that's true
but I'll tell you something else
and but for the people that aren't or
maybe a little on the fence stick with
perks I think that's a happy media I'm
not going to tell you to do nothing
life's hard stick with perks or a little
vikey
because the Oxys are too much and it's
like abstinence only education it's not
realistic the kids are gonna [__] anyway
and have kids so you got to teach them a
little bit about the condo but you can't
teach them in the fifth grade there's
got to be a little there's a little you
know when you're in high school you go
here's the thing this is what you use if
you're gonna do it don't do it but if
you're gonna do it wear the condom if
you and that's the way out that's what
I'm telling you don't do it but if
you're gonna do it take a vicodin
take a percocet and take a nice drive
around Connecticut and take a nice walk
go antiquing with two Vicodin you don't
need Oxycontin that's the pre you take a
couple of Vicodin you go antiquing on a
Sunday in Connecticut you have a warm
lobster roll it's fine that's fine you
gotta learn to live with that level of
intoxicate you have to learn you know my
friend's mother who is a prostitute but
was brilliant in her own way said once I
handle my drugs
I I handle my drugs I've learned to
I'm good at drugs she said that because
I've learned to handle my drugs handle
your day she said that that's when we
were 13. handle your drugs she said in
her kitchen to us my friend my lesbian
friend handle your drugs she said you
have to handle your drugs you have to
you you can't drink to the point where
you vomit you can't
people have used substances for
enjoyment forever and it's not a popular
thing to say especially the sober guy I
lack the power of using recreational
drugs many people do not I know people
that drink often and smoke marijuana a
lot I know people that go on Ayahuasca
Retreats and have horrible ideas for
scripts afterwards I know people that
take DMT I know people that do
everything that roll on Molly they go to
Raves they're 48 and they're at Raves
whatever it doesn't matter but they can
do it I cannot I have lost the power
over that I'm I'm incapable of it my
advice is to the people that are capable
of it be good at your drugs be good at
your drugs it's not an abstinence
message it doesn't work
telling everyone to not do drugs is not
really maybe realistic or even ideal
how much funner are certain people drunk
how much better
are certain people if they have the edge
taken off right there's nothing wrong
with that I'm just saying stick with
Percocet
which is more than enough and for many
of you Vicodins enough oxycontin's way
too much
it's way too much you got to stay away
from it
and yes it's a slippery slope they'll
say yes it is a slippery slope yes if
many of you who start with Vicodin or
Percocet will end up uh doing Oxycontin
but I guess many people who start
sucking [__] will eventually [__] a dog
it's not my problem I'm saying be good
at your drugs as my friends prostitute
mother said who used to sell us weed
where was I before that I was on
something important when all of these
rich families that know exactly what's
going on kick out one family and decide
to Blacklist them they decide to shame
them and say they are uniquely evil
they are uniquely evil and bad and they
have corrupted the system
single-handedly we don't know how they
did it we just went to every fundraiser
with them vacation with them sat next to
them hung out with them maybe [__] them
did drugs with them donated money to
every political campaign with them saw
them out at every fundraiser for the
last 30 or 40 years but their lives have
been a mystery to us we don't know what
they're doing over there we have no idea
what they're doing but it's bad
bad and it's uniquely evil they are
different
they have they have polluted a great
system the pharmaceutical system the
system of research and development and
Innovation the system that makes people
in America better and healthy isn't it a
country of healthy people they're always
getting better that's what they've done
they've made everyone better and then
this evil family of warlocks called the
Sackler family invented the plague and
no one knew it was a plague even though
we prescribed it for 30 40 years
and it's that evil family that was we
don't know what they were doing we knew
that they had a drug called Oxycontin
you know the studies weren't and we were
not shown whenever the rich decide to
evict and I mean the real not people
like me stop calling me Richard it's not
true
it's not true
the thing the real Rich the people that
are insanely wealthy and they they're
they're cabals of powerful people
they're factions power factions and
control
and every now and then they evict
something they decide to evict somebody
this happens all the time they go you're
out
because the way these things work is all
all of the way all of the businesses in
America at the high end are cartels kind
of they're like cartels and then
eventually what happens is the public
gets angry they become enraged because
there's some crime that's uncovered
and then everybody's got to decide at
the midnight meeting how quickly and how
cleanly they can disown whoever either
committed said crime or whoever they can
pin the crime on and convince them that
they are a complete uh this is a outlier
this is not the way we are doing good
business we're doing the right thing the
vast majority those two words whenever
somebody's using those words it tends to
be a lie if they have something to gain
from it they go the vast majority of
what they really mean is that we are all
still we all still have each other's
backs
but we're throwing them out we're
kicking them out they're out
this is not to say that Oxycontin is
good and you should put it on your
frozen yogurt this is to say that it's
always interesting when the most which
by the way RFK
they attack him because he's going after
the industry that makes more money in
this country really than any other the
pharmaceutical industry is allowed to
advertise in America and New Zealand and
that is it
growing up I saw so many ads for all of
these drugs that cured everything from
hair loss to erectile dysfunction to to
anxiety to insomnia every single thing
that you could imagine there was a blue
or pink or purple pill for
allergies all the allergies we get from
the crap food we eat you know the
Claritin ads people running through the
Meadows look at me I can breathe again
everything the pharmaceutical companies
do
um
is now off limits you cannot criticize
them at all they are an incredibly
powerful Lobby
and since they with the vaccine they
were able to fuse with Public Health
and criticizing anything they do you
became a conspiracy nut job and a whack
and a crank but that's why RFK
is
Making Waves and pissing people off and
that's why the media is ignoring him
because those news networks that are not
letting him come on and criticize the
pharmaceutical company the ads for those
news networks are all pharmaceutical ads
because the median age of a viewer of
cable news is like 115 years old their
skin is thin it's like Biden it just it
spread very thin like a thin layer of
butter on toast the skin is spread very
thin and the bones protrude out of it
and if you touch it even so slightly it
becomes blue those are the people that
watch uh the cable news shows and those
are the people
that need the pharmaceutical ads I did
enjoy painkiller uzo Adobe is brilliant
and I don't think the sacklers
um you know are upstanding fine people
but none of them are that's the point
none of them are so when everybody gets
together and goes here's the bad guy
look this way
here's but I was proud of my mom to she
was one of those hot chicks selling
speed yeah because she was really hot
back in the day and she was one of those
hot chicks selling speed and I was proud
of her for that
um because I thought that was a cool job
so speaking of my mother I want to show
you
these beautiful beautiful things that my
aunt just sent to me I had no idea they
existed make them big make everyone be
able to see them these are paintings
get them up get both of them up
these are paintings that my mother did
before she died these are
paintings
I believe they are maybe watercolor on
canvas acrylic on canvas I don't know
they are
they mean a lot to me they're her last
works
and they are incredibly emotional and
mean a lot to me
we are selling them
and we're selling them because she would
want them sold
and
is it unreasonable
to start debating
at twenty five thousand dollars
for a dead artist with two works
for Patricia Dillon original
what about fi here's here's what I'll
say
tell me
on social media
the amount of money you were willing to
pay for these paintings
I don't really want them they don't fit
the color scheme in my homes no they
don't fit the color scheme in my homes
my aunt said you want them I said no I'm
working with designers
we can't fit it in I've spoken to these
people and
it's there's very tough because there's
a whole scheme there's things that
highlight other things and things colors
that bounce off you people I couldn't
even explain it to you but it's just not
going to work and get the other one up
with the palm trees I think it's a
little stronger
um
so again if you want these Patricia
Dylan Originals we can make but it's
going to cost
money I don't think it should be free
this is a recently deceased artist who
has two works
could we do a gallery show with two
works you could right like an exhibition
yeah yes yes well that might happen
I mean I have an art dealer I should
call
no I have I don't think she'll answer
but I I genuinely have an art dealer who
because I like art
I like art and
hi Sophia how are you good how are you
good let me ask you a question this is
crazy my mother was kind of like an
artist she painted two things she's
recently deceased uh oh I appreciate it
she fought a long hard battle but she's
got these two like beautiful things I
just want to show them to you I don't
know
I want to show them to you because I
don't know what you could do with them
but like you know she was schizophrenic
and I know I mean not to be crass about
it but I know some of the art World
likes stuff like that yeah you know what
I mean because
[Music]
yes well and that's the thing because I
think it unlocks something that's a
little brilliant and there might be
someone you know that I mean not even to
monetize I'm not concerned about the
money but somebody might look at this
and go there's some real value in it
because of the schizophrenia
send it to me I'd love to see you yes
all right thank you so much I appreciate
it
right thank you
are we not living in a folks are we not
living in a great world folks are we not
living in a great world
I mean the art world is it not fun
Savage she's a Savage she's a nut
I'm gonna send these [__] paintings to
this person
this demon and we're gonna sell them to
some rich [__]
but not the sacklers not the set not
them
[Music]
not them I'm gonna sell my dead
schizophrenic mother's paintings because
the system's good but not the sacklers
my art dealer likes that she goes let's
pimp out those synapses firing but not
quite meeting up but not the sacrifice
not good the sacklers
but these are on the Block they're going
to the block [__] you you know what
you're not messaging on social media
we're gonna do a show this [__] she's
legit legit this [__] she's legit legit
you know it we're doing a show for my
dead mother's art
we're doing the show of my dead mother's
art if you're not into it you're not
into it but people like that it's a
schizophrenia you you you you [__]
Normie Minds can't a [__] comprehend
because what my mother's painting there
she's not really painting a sailboat and
palm trees what cheese but and you know
what we need to do we need to kind of
dress these up a little bit right yeah
these could sell for a hundred thousand
each if I get them I'll get my aunt to
send me them and then instead of them
just being these like shitty things in
the middle of it we'll put like a a
bloody stencil of Richard Nixon's face
and I swear to God I'm not kid you put a
bloody stencil of Nixon's face and Let
it bleed and go she's a Vietnam era
schizophrenic
spell it out shell it out
absolutely true
it's it's amazingly true
I'm I'm actually to be honest with you
I'm I'm sad there's only two two let me
call my aunt because frankly we might be
getting more and I I I am praying to God
there's more give me more
what if we glued the Beanie Babies onto
them
what if we glued the Beanie Babies on hi
Donna very quick quick question can't
really talk long are those two paintings
of my mother are those the only
paintings she's done or those her only
works
wait say that say that again those two
paintings that my mother did are those
her only works
I might have one of my own you know that
I have somewhere that I packed and
brought I'll get all of her works I want
to do a gallery show but all right I'll
I'll
just like the pine tree get them all get
them all get them all I'll call you back
thank you we're in it baby
it's hard they just got out of the US
Open start start scheduling Richard
Nixon's bloody face or some crap they'll
like on my mother's kind of boring
Landscapes that are that are kind of
uninspiring start stenciling something
kind of banks geared up sex it up
let's do a gallery show of my uh dead
schizophrenic mother's art It's My
Mother by the way people that may be
offended by this or think this is
cold-hearted there is nobody that would
want her work to sell
how do you say posthumously there's
nobody that would want her art to sell
posthumously more than my mother nobody
my mother would be happy that I'm using
uh the art that we found in her mental
institution to uh enrich myself and if
you don't have a mother like that then
you got to get a new mama you got to get
a new mother they want they want their
work appreciated and it doesn't have to
be in their lifetime that's a great
thing about art
and if you think I'm kidding about this
you don't know me and have not watched
this show there will be a gal I will do
a gallery show in New York City if this
woman I will you have to just stencil
the faces get me maybe a Henry Kissinger
Nixon we got to do something we got it's
Vietnam it's retro her mind was ruined
she was a hippie and it was fun but her
mind got you know because we gotta sell
to the rich hippie contingent
they're older now they're rich they're
wandering around Malibu or Soho
uh these are the people that you know
were these free love wild types you know
um and and uh you know they're really
excited about Pete budget
I like Pete bootage I like mayor Pete
but you know these are the people that
were doing like you know they were
having five sums with Country Joe and
the Fish you know but now they're
excited about mayor P you know it's like
life life can be long sometimes and
that's the problem but
these people that you know those are the
people that we're going for with kind of
that 60s and such give me a little
warplane you put a war plane in the
middle of one of these A stenciled
warplane in red that it looks like blood
I'm telling you right now we're in
that's all art is it's fake
it's not real
dude I sometimes I want to buy tickets
to something and I'm like when I was
buying the Free Speech night with very
uh
wise and Grimes I was stressed out
because I'm like I want a night of free
speech where can I go you know it's
important to get a night of free speech
out there get a little
free speech
so I went to the feminist free speech
uh debate but a lot of my friends were
like call me they were stressed out they
were like [__] where I how do we
get these tickets I'm like what about
the game time app they're like what I'm
like uh the game time app
and they're like is that it we can see
Grimes I go yeah
flash Shields last minute tickets easy
to find and buy tickets for every kind
of event in your area images of seat
views lowest price guarantee even cancel
agent protection job loss protection
things like that
forget planning months in advance game
time has deals on tickets right up to
the day of the event get exclusive Flash
Deals on tickets for football basketball
baseball concerts comedy theater and
more
the game time guarantee means you'll get
the best price I'm telling you right now
download the game time app create an
account musicaltim don't take my word
for it go do it now
maybe that is taking my word for it but
figure it out for yourself but do it now
use the code Tim for twenty dollars off
your first purchase
would you be to see me
terms apply again create an account
redeem code Tim for twenty dollars off
download game time today I'm telling you
folks
it is a good app
this is one of those good apps
legitimately and
it is one of those apps where you need
it because you are buying things in the
show
uh I'm sorry it's late you're buying
things
in the out there in the world you're
gonna buy them anyway why not buy them
efficiently and quickly it's last minute
last minute
like Princess Diana Bear right here
I I want to go to the game time app
why do you want to go to the game time
app princess night well I'm the soul of
Diana actually
and I was murdered because I was dating
a Palestinian and the British royal
family couldn't take that chance so they
murdered me with the Mossad
well that's wacky isn't it yes but now
Marcel lives in this bear and this isn't
even a real bear
it's the fake bear that your [__]
fans think is real
well that's not a nice thing to say I
died before cancel culture you're not
going to cancel me I've already been
canceled in a limousine by some very bad
people and my only regret is that I
couldn't see crimes debate the girl from
Red Scare about feminism because all
didn't have the Game Time Out download
the game to our map create an account
and use the code Tim for 20 off your
first purchase I also am not thrilled
that my [__] of a son is dating Meghan
Markle as I agree with you I think she's
sort of a low rent fish wife
so much of what people have to do when
they own a business is to promote growth
and change
that's really what it comes down to
they can't worry about a lot of the
clerical jobs the back office you know
right now we're in the Calm before the
holiday storm if you are in any type of
e-commerce business and if you know
let me tell you a story about a friend I
had
this is a real story that might help
people because I'm talking about a a
thing today called ship station that
might made you avoid the fate of a
friend that I have because ship station
can quickly and easily update crucial
order information reduce errors it's
effortlessly effortless integration
anywhere you sell online including
Amazon Etsy eBay Shopify and more it
manages orders prints labels Compares
rates optimize every should they work
with every carrier UPS FedEx a postal
service
my friend he wanted to do it himself he
said that he started a business it was
sports memorabilia and he goes I want to
do it myself and he got his wife who was
involved as well and
um
she was taking a sabbatical because she
had was pregnant
I don't know what they call that
maternity leave
but she was a teacher so I think
sabbatical is kind of an interesting
maternity leave
okay
and this guy
this gentleman
starting an e-commerce business with her
well
I don't even want to I mean I don't even
want to say it
it got so bad with the shipping
of the labels and the the they were
trying to keep track of the orders it
got so bad that he cut the baby out of
her
and killed the baby in front of her and
then killed her
I don't even like
to think about it because to me it's
like
it's
ship station has Enterprise solutions
that reduce Warehouse cost and improve
profitability
over 130 000 companies have grown it
would be one thing to kill her but
debate and then her it's you know
go to shipstation.com and use it code
Tim Dillon today and sign up for a free
60-day trial that's shipstation.com code
t-i-m-d-i-l-l-o-n bye
Hunter Biden
sadly was indicted this guy is uh
indicted now he's facing 10 years
because of a gun charge
here's what you got to respect about
Hunter Biden
um he's still showing up
to life
like you know like he's still with the
family he's still out
remember a few months ago you saw him he
was out on the balcony and then he kind
of left to do something or other inside
but he was out on the balcony with
everybody he's another artist it's an
episode about art if Hunter Biden can
sell his art like my mother can't
if this guy can sell his art my mother
cannot my mother was a law-abiding
citizen
so under Biden sadly is indicted on gun
charges and um uh
uh it's it's not looking great he
purchased a gun in 2018 the first time
in U.S history the justice department is
charged the child of a sitting president
the three charges include making false
statements on a federal firearms form
and possession of a firearm as a
prohibited person
Biden's now getting very old
he's not getting old now he's been old
he's been old
but now the laser focus on him has made
people realize
how
old he is
he's confused he's wandering around he
has probably early onset dementia
something like that and they don't know
what they got to get rid of him they're
trying the powers that be I don't
believe want him I I think they believe
he's too much of a liability now and
that someone else could that someone
else could win and maybe open an
investigation into any of these things
right the Russia gate hoax or whatever
the hell's going on in Ukraine with the
Biden family like there are people that
don't want there's members uh of the
political establishment that do not want
somebody coming in there especially an
outsider flinging up the flinging open
uh all these uh files and going what the
hell's been going on here they don't
want that the only reason to really run
Biden at his age is to continue some
kind of cover-up I mean this isn't I
mean think about it rationally and
ignore politics for a minute the only
reason you have a guy wandering around a
stage that can't speak is because you're
terrified of whoever comes in next
there's no reason that you would have
prop this corpse up unless you weren't
scared that the person that came in next
would be able to like start
digging up dirt you know do you have the
thing where Biden he
yeah well they abruptly end his press
conference yeah
it's really
it's really weird
yes a whole insect this was in a Vietnam
earlier this week what by the way so I
was talking to a friend of mine about
this on Shelter Island and he made a
good point he's like it's kind of like
elder abuse right right it's like elder
abuse you know people in his family keep
putting him out in front of the podium
and keep making him talk and there's
almost like some weird thing where a
friend of mine made a point where it was
like
maybe Hunter Biden's not confusing his
dad like you [__] shut the [__] up
and like because you know Biden having
the power of the presidency is maybe one
of the reasons all these dominoes aren't
falling right
and I think Hunter Biden knows that I
mean
he's probably telling his dad like you
have to support me you have to back me
you you know I mean so take a look at
Biden here it's crazy and I I actually
by the way kind of feel bad for Biden
because he's so old
he doesn't know what he's doing he's
like a pawn in in something
and and I mean he's been you know a
pretty consistent demon
legislatively in every other way his
whole life I'm not just saying he should
we should feel bad from like like many
of them you know I mean that being said
I I truly don't believe he knows where
he is I think we've we've gotten to a
point where
it's an apolitical statement to make
this is not a political statement poll
after Paul says majority of like
Democrats want another option because
the guy is [__] ancient
but I don't think he knows where he is
so then the question is why is this
going on it's not enough that they just
don't have another person that's not
enough right
right that's not enough there's there's
there's people they're not great but the
Republicans don't have anyone great
either right except Trump who's been
indicted a bunch of times right he's
he's the only one with the gravitas to
kind of you know get in the ring and
he'd be a formidable candidate the rest
of them are bombing DeSantis is deflated
you know Nikki Haley Vivek ramaswamy
it's not so the Democrats have Governors
they have people they have Senators have
Congress people
um
I think it's got to be something out
it's got to be another reason
that
this guy they have to run this guy again
it seems weird to me it seems odd
and I don't know what it is but take a
look at this it's uh
weird
about we talked about at the conference
overall we talked about stability we
talked about making sure that the third
world the excuse me third world the uh
the the uh the southern hemisphere had
access to change it had access it wasn't
confrontational at all thank you
everybody this ends account press
conference thanks everyone
thank you
yeah so you say in the third world it's
not the third world he doesn't know what
he's talking about look at the jazz
music plays
how beautiful is this look at him he has
no idea where he is
[Music]
he doesn't know where he is
he doesn't know where he is the poor
guys they're telling they're talking
about his son he's walking off to Jazz
is that the music they played in the
room I mean Jesus Christ play his exit
one more time it's one of the greatest
things I've ever seen with the jazz
music I thought that was dubbed in no no
no the fact that this is the real music
playing as this guy leaves is the
craziest thing I've ever seen talk about
the sun setting on the Empire I mean
watch this
thank you
[Music]
with every person I've met with yeah
he's talking he's not even in the mic
and then he just walks off to Jazz
just some fun soft jazz
that's true yeah I mean it's uh it's
terrible that uh he's in the state he's
in and nobody's rescuing him he needs to
be rescued
this is a Seal Team Six Rescue Mission
and the only way to rescue him is to
like get him put him out of his misery I
mean not kill him but like get him out
of get him out of the [__] Oval
Office
let the guy be I mean we really torture
people in this country you know we don't
ever let it end
we don't ever let it end in this country
how old is that guy uh late 70s right
that guy's in his late 70s and you know
someone came to him and they're like the
country is calling you know you have to
answer I was 80. he's 80.
and you know they tell them every day
they're like history is calling sir you
know like will you and he's like
history because it's just the people
behind the scenes are running the whole
thing and if you could tell the way he
walks off the stage I mean God he's old
he's not gonna win
and they can't run him and I believe
that's what they're thinking now
but they can't run Amy Klobuchar could
shade a salad with a comb once remember
when they didn't have a fork at any
clubuchar she threw a state learner
assistance hadn't then ate a salad with
a fork I'm sorry with a uh comb shade is
salad with a comb out uh Elizabeth
Warren is a joke she's a literal
punchline P Buddha judge
is uh a CIA gay which is probably not
the most attractive right now he took
three months off to raise a child he did
not have I mean that seems odd and I'm
I'm all for gay people being parents if
they're good at it but like taking 90
days off while trains are derailing and
they're spilling waste all over [__]
Ohio or wherever the hell it is
Pennsylvania
um it's uh
it's crazy so
it's just an ugly reality now that they
don't have anyone Sanders is too old
Gavin Newsom is probably their best bet
even though he's hated and he's the
governor of a hated state which he's
made quite a mess of
but they cannot run this guy and then we
have Kamala who's incapable of
communicating uh is a prosecutor a cop
you know Democrats love that
a resident of the hated state California
doesn't she have a white husband
yeah right so I mean it's across the
board she doesn't check any of the boxes
right she it it's just not
cool
nobody's into it you know nobody's into
it and that's unfortunate you know what
I was saying the other day to somebody I
was having lunch with somebody
and I said 35 of all fatal car accidents
in curb A Team 6 pm at midnight they
said no way
I said people aged 25 to 34 have the
highest amount of drivers involved in
car crashes people age 15 to 24 had the
highest rate of emergency room visits
due to car accidents of all age groups
they were like what
I said Morgan and Morgan is I was
getting free like we're having launched
I was kind of going and they were like
what but
I told him I said Morgan and Morgan is
America's largest injury firm they have
100 offices Nationwide more than 800
lawyers
I said with over 15 billion dollars
recovered from over 300 000 clients
Morgan and Morgan has a proven track
record of fighting to get you full and
fair compensation at this point they
were going what's wrong with you stop I
just want to have lunch I said Morgan
and Morgan has been fighting for the
people for over 35 years submitting an
injury claimed with Morgan and Morgan is
easy
I'm telling you right now people are
going to get injured I don't want it to
happen no one wants it to happen but
it's going to happen because this is
life
it was profound
now you need lawyers to get get what's
yours get what's rightfully yours out
there
um
so I'm telling you
it's a bit of gonna drink clay with
Morgan and Morgan it's easy baby trying
to predict what celebrity will be
roasted on my next episode's heart oh
God I hate when they ride it they're so
bad stop [__] writing be lawyers
oh
it's a good Law Firm folks they don't
charge you unless they win and it isn't
out with life's about it's winning if
you're ever injured you could check out
Morgan and Morgan their fees free unless
they win for more information go to four
other people.com
Tim
[Music]
for the people.comtim or dial pound law
pound 29 from your cell phone that's
forthepeople.com Tim
or pound law pound 529 from yourself
this is a paid advertisement Lauren
bobert was kicked out of Beetlejuice the
musical uh the traveling
the thing about musicals is when they
um leave Broadway or even when they are
still on Broadway
but I think it's when they close but
maybe Beetlejuice is still open I don't
know it was like a national tour
yeah I was on one of those years ago for
Andy gate your gun when I was 11 and my
mother went with me for like three
months we toured around the country and
then you know in the real Annie Get Your
Gun on Broadway the Gina Davis was the
star she was a movie star and she played
Annie Oakley and then we had this woman
who's like this Ethel Merman
impersonator
uh
and she was you know the touring version
of the musical often it's a far fall
you know what I mean on Broadway musical
have like Josh Groban and then when it
goes on tour around the country it'll be
like Joey Fatone like it's uh it's a
apocalyptic
fall in terms of the cast but
they didn't deserve this whatever she
was doing she got kicked out of uh
Beetlejuice the musical
for causing a disturbance
she was in the theater I think vaping
talking
they cited incident report it obtained
which representatives of the Buell
Theater in downtown Denver say a group
of people were asked to leave after
vaping singing recording causing a
disturbance well they were getting into
it she's a hillbilly
you gotta let her get into it a little
bit she's a hillbilly you know that's
the thing I don't really want to defend
her here but she is a hillbilly and
there is a culture they have and some of
it is kind of singing along and vaping
and stomping your feet and doing like
ham bone and jug bands and stuff I mean
this isn't not a woman who's like seeing
shows at the West End the West End of
London or on Broadway I mean she's a
heck she's a straight up hillbilly and
I'm not saying that in a disrespectful
manner you know publicly uh privately I
am but I'm just saying like
this is who she is that's her culture is
to kind of sing along and be a lad she's
a classless animal is what I mean like
so but you know I don't know was was she
being that disruptive I don't know I
wasn't in the theater
she probably was
but that's the thing she's unaware like
the only reason she's going to see any
type of theater is because it's
Beetlejuice that's it
the only shows that Lauren bobert would
ever go see are movies she's seen before
uh you know she's never going to
she was she wasn't gonna go see like the
ferryman on Broadway the chess
Butterworth the brilliant Sam Mendes
thing that Gaffigan told me to see and I
saw three times it was amazing
she's not gonna go see Death of a
Salesman Lauren Boberg she's not gonna
go see A View From The Bridge
she's not gonna go see a Shakespeare in
the park she's not like oh Othello is
playing let's go see Othello she wants
to see Beetlejuice she's a hillbilly and
I'm not saying there's anything wrong
with Beetlejuice but there probably is I
haven't seen it I'm guessing
I'm sure it's fun
I'm sure it's fun and Goofy and silly
but that's the only theater
I almost side with her here
she's trying
like
she's trying she's the Waffle House
employee she's a bartender she's and and
don't hit me with the classes or [__] of
like well she could still be brilliant
she ain't she ain't
yes you could you could work at
Applebee's and be a genius you could
you'd not most likely I'm guessing law
of averages
she's a goon
her and her husband beat the [__] out of
each other on their lawn the cops come
to the house uh
uh she's like Sarah Palin 3.0 she's
getting divorced because they can't stop
beating each other up
they can't stop I don't know
smashing the windows of each other's
cars out with [__] bats they find
around I mean they're like a fun couple
the sex is probably really fun because
then they attack each other with like
weapons you know you know that she's
been barricaded in the bathroom and then
she goes and talks about family values
and how important they are and you know
her kids are screaming and crying
and he's like I can open this door you
know there's been a moment in her house
where her kids are in their rooms
they're terrified they're they're locked
in their rooms they're terrified and
they're screaming and she's in the
bathroom and he's kicking the door and
he's like open this [__] door open
this [__] door make no mistake that's
her home life
that's her home life she's probably
thrown around and for good reason she's
probably gonna mouth on her
she's probably got a mouth on her and
for good reason she's probably thrown
around let's be honest
now let's be very honest now this is
very I often get into problems here on
this show because I just speak
extemporaneously but she's got a mouth
on and there's probably reason she gets
shoved in the kitchen there's she it's
not out of nowhere shoving okay when
Lauren bobert trips going down the back
steps it's not for no reason she has a
toxic mouth and and I don't I am not and
I can't believe I have to say it's
amazing that I have any representation
in this town because occasionally I have
to say things like this I am not
defending hitting women but
Lauren bobert is not getting shoved
accidentally
she doesn't have to lock herself in the
bathroom accidentally she's not getting
chased when he chases her in a car when
her husband I think his name's Jason I
forget but when her husband gets in a
car and he chases her around
okay it's not by accident she's she's
she's a live wire
she's the problem
she insults him she probably talks [__]
about his dick
I'm guessing because she's not going for
like deep intellectual things but that
hurts him and he can't say [__] about
his dick can't talk about Jason bobert's
dick is it Jason bobert yeah yes
so this woman who again had to leave her
house
because
of family values and she was getting
through our mouth
was getting her into she was her mouth
was as a as a black older woman would
say her mouth
um was writing checks that she couldn't
cash right because Jason was probably he
had had enough of her he'd had enough of
her and she's probably like I'm gonna
end up dead
I bet one day he looked at her and it
was like it was like full OJ eyes like
I'm gonna cut your [__] head off and
put it on a pike and again not for
nothing not for no reason she was
probably very inappropriate and she said
I'm gonna I'm gonna die here I gotta go
and she's just trying to go to
Beetlejuice because she's a hillbilly
she's a hillbilly with a big mouth who
brings Whoopins on herself that she does
kind of deserve
and she's also in Congress
she's also in Cut let's not leave that
out she's the elected representative of
the state of Colorado whatever that
means whatever that means but I have no
interest in that I only look at a
character study she is a saucy sexy
bartender who knows how to [__]
she knows how to get on a dick and ride
it she can make a man come which is more
than I can say for some of these
squawking liberal Birds up in the
Northeast where all sex is death I'm
just saying I I'm not even having sex
with women I'm hearing it I'm hearing it
people talk to me they share things with
me so you get a little spicy hillbilly
like Lauren bobert who's been [__]
since she's 12. she is a she's a real
Southern uh Carnival [__] and in a good
way in a good way it makes a man hard
when when a woman knows how to [__] and
will [__] she will suck a [__] she will
get on her knees and she will suck a
[__] and she doesn't care if you've
showered you don't need to shower she
likes little spice she likes little
spice she can snap your eyes will roll
back in your head she knows how to [__]
but she's also got a mouth and she's
gonna get you in jail she's gonna get
you in jail those Northeastern cold
liberal women will plot to destruction
of your life for years and then they'll
take everything from you you won't even
know what happened they'll just end up
somewhere in a [__] Bungalow in
Florida and you'll be in some apartment
going what the [__] hop you won't even
know you won't even know but bobert it's
just it's she's she's a spicy Saucy
dangerous woman who will make you kill
her she will not stop until you kill her
that's the type of lady she is
she's gonna just say the wrong thing and
you're gonna want to kill her
and she's in Beetlejuice
just trying to have fun with her friends
her friends are also pure Isle white
trash garbage people
they have no education they have no
class they have no distinction but what
I will say about them they're probably
all decent Fox and they like drugs and
alcohol and you know what I don't mind
any of that I can't do it anymore but
they're not the hanging out with Lauren
bobert is not the least fun you will
have it is not the least fun you will
have
Lauren Boba because she's all like gay
marriage gotta go and there shouldn't be
no abortions and everybody in the Jews
are running around [__] with
everybody and the moral code but she'll
get on her knees and suck your [__]
after she's done a line off of it she's
an old school
[__] like you know bar Made From Dusk
Till Dawn get on the bar vampire core
and that's important
and the the thing about her is
a woman like that she's destined for
something I don't know where Lauren
bobert goes but I like that she's still
because she doesn't respect theater
she's like these [__] [__] they girl
make me laugh and they better dance and
I'm gonna [__] do what it I don't
even know if she talks like this but she
does you know but she doesn't but I
don't care but the point is it's not
like she respects the art of theater
she's there to see Beetlejuice she's a
hillbilly who just had the divorce her
husband because if not he was gonna cut
her head up he was gonna kill her
and This Woman's destined for something
I don't know what it is it could be a
bad end it might be a great end maybe
one day she'll lead us all I don't know
she's not like Lightfoot who's iconic
she doesn't have an I.E she's not iconic
we can't put her on a pedestal we cannot
worship her we worship Lord Lightfoot
who just started teaching in Harvard and
watch your ass I'm enrolling We cannot
put her on a pedestal and worship her as
the bill and end-all and uh you know the
the greatest politician maybe in my
lifetime is the great Lori Lightfoot I
mean that bobert shows promise she shows
promise she's a spicy Carnival [__] and
I like that and that's something there's
something to be said for that there's
something to be said for a woman
um who has that thing because they don't
the thing about people like her
is they they tend not to care
about how like there she doesn't have
the ability
to
[Music]
play any type of long game it's doesn't
uh happener people like her are very
interesting to watch uh they can't play
the long game at all they are they are
just victims of their environment and
circumstances which they've created they
create their environment and
circumstances and they just kind of get
thrown around and knocked about and they
react in crazy ways and they're all fun
to watch and they people like that
either get pretty successful because
they're they get to be pretty Adept at
riding the waves that they've created or
they just get you know knocked around
too much and you know you never see them
again we don't know
we do not know
my mother's art is not a joke and it
will be uh for sale and we will and by
the way I'm on tour I don't know if
anyone knows that
but I'm coming to Cincinnati Ohio I'm
coming into Lexington Kentucky I'm
coming to Davenport Iowa Des Moines Iowa
Omaha Nebraska
Sacramento Perth and Australia Perth
Adelaide Sydney Brisbane Melbourne
Auckland New Zealand Christchurch New
Zealand Rochester New York New York New
York Pittsburgh Pennsylvania Houston
Texas Detroit Michigan Toronto Ontario
um and then Brea for New Year's
we're gonna maybe grab we're gonna add
some Boston to Florida
early January you know we are going to
do a lot of those things it's
interesting it's interesting when you
look at the character studies of some of
these people and how they're going to
react
uh
you know like the the better version of
like bobert is like Christy gnome from
uh Dakota who's a little bit more who
Chris Matthews said Trump would probably
tap as his uh vice president the RFK and
Cheryl interview is doing very well RFK
made a lot of cool points and I I made
up you know the we had a blackout and
I'm like I thought we were trying to
kill him and then the media ran with
that because nobody wants to talk about
that guy's points
Josh Brown called him out from CNBC was
like you know Vanguard State Street and
BlackRock represent millions of regular
people and
and then I was like but you know me and
Ray comp we're talking and it's like
RFK if he wants to get any traction
needs to get rougher and tougher and be
like I'm gonna put Larry Fink in jail
I'll kill him I'll kill Larry if you
like he's got look Trump won by saying
the most outlandish things I'll put you
in jail because you'd be in jail
remember the things he said
he's RFK has been a little too
statesmanlike I think he's got to go out
there and he's really going to say I'm
going to put these people in jail
I'll put them in jail I'll shut down
their companies
you know I'm gonna I'll Kill Them All
I'll Kill Them All I'm gonna kill him
well how do you stop them from doing
that we kill them I'll kill them
if he said ah day one on day one of my
bread you remember Game of Thrones well
the scene without Ned stock was patted
in front of his daughter who is his
daughter's handsome Santa
and Sansa fell down because she's Our
Father beheaded I will be ahead Larry
Fink in front of his daughter
on the first day of the president on day
one day one of my presidency I'll be
ahead Larry Fink in front of his
daughter and she will collapse
like Sansa Stark that scene and Game of
Thrones I'll cut his [__] I'll cut
his head off and then I'll I'll cut
everybody's head off until people start
listening but that's
it's fun to imitate but I can't keep
doing it because then I will sound like
that and by the way
even though the voice might be a little
tough you got to listen to him because
he says a lot of interesting things I
gotta be I think he's the best candidate
in the race I know that that might sound
crazy
he seems like the most interesting
candidate in the race
just invite me to the compound
I just want to go to the compound yeah
this port
can they book me to do a show at the
Kennedy comp by the way here's how my
career wouldn't should end
if I was booked to do a show at the
Kennedy Compound on Hyannis Port I might
retire
it might be the end I've been doing this
I'm 38 years old I started when I'm 25.
I've mortgaged
years of my life to just get funny
enough and good enough to to hopefully
do something people enjoy
and I started it I had zero dollars I
had no money and I was coming out of an
industry that was dissolving and I was
living in a shitty apartment I had all
these credit problems and
blah blah blah who cares fast forward
if I got booked if I was standing there
doing comedy in front of the entire
Kennedy family
Kennedy Compound in Hyannis Port it is
my Madison Square Garden it wouldn't be
a good shot I wouldn't it wouldn't go
that well it wouldn't matter
it doesn't matter you see it's not about
that it would be fine
I'd have some of the room some of the
time put it that way it wouldn't be a
kill box to Kennedy combat and Hyannis
Port it's probably uptight you know
every time a bird flies by everybody
goes
but it would be kind of a fitting way
go listen I
I'm done as a stand-up comedian here
because I've reached the heights
of what I could do
because it is a joke I would have made
years ago I would have said something
like
if people say where where's what's your
goal is a stand-up Community yeah I want
to do the Kennedy Compound Labor Day I
want to do the Labor Day Kennedy
Compound
but it would be hilarious now it's not
going to happen but it would be and I
probably wouldn't quit because I'm a
dumb addict who would just keep doing
crap anyway you just keep doing stuff
but
it would be something to think about if
I shot a special there live at the
Kennedy Compound
and it'll be a
70 minute special and it wouldn't be
good
but it would be fascinating to just see
the Kennedy everyone just sitting there
in white yeah you know it's Labor Day
they're all sitting there
you know
what if I did Bobby's voice the whole
time and killed murdered
murdered
it's interesting
it's interesting these families and the
way they operate and some of them
sustain and some of them last for years
and years and years that's what the
bullets of the world can't do they they
don't get long game they don't they
can't put their put their emotions down
the Kennedys the bushes the these
dynasties they don't just happen you
have to learn how to control your
emotions so you can hate the elites you
can hate the East Coast establishment
you can I think you could find this
strain of human being in Texas you could
find them in California the people that
are able to subordinate their emotions
they're able to kind of shut their
emotions off and then you know basically
kind of
play the long game you know and that's
something that the Lauren boberts of the
world can't do that's what makes them so
fun but you know I don't know if they
will endure
like Lori Lightfoot could it was not
indoors it was a flash of the patch it
was fun and she's gone there's no light
foot Dynasty
they don't know how to do it there there
is a way to do it that's the thing there
is an actual way to to be a politician
for Generations in this country as it's
presently constituted
I'm not saying that's a good thing I'm
saying that's a thing that there is a
way to do it there's
Lauren bobert can't even think about
this
we have dynasties that have assassinated
presidents engaged in drug running human
trafficking fixing elections this [__]
can't not get kicked out of Beetlejuice
you're not gonna make it you won't make
it
you will not make it it will not happen
it will not happen
if you can't figure out a way to not
make the news for getting out of
Beetlejuice how are you going to
assassinate a president or run a fake
war or flood the streets of Washington
DC with crack or all the other things
our leaders have done to stay where they
are
who invented crack the sacklers
good night everyone